[Musique]
une mère de drapeau israélien blanc et
bleu
des messages pour le Premier ministre et
pour son gouvernement
[Musique]
ces israéliens et s'opposent à une
réforme du système judiciaire déposé par
le gouvernement de coalition de la
droite et de l'extrême droite dirigée
par Benyamin Netanyahou revenu au
pouvoir à la fin décembre
permettrait au parlement israélien
d'avoir plus de contrôle sur la
nomination des juges mais surtout le
gouvernement aurait la possibilité
d'annuler une décision de la Cour
suprême et par le fait même une loi
votée par le Parlement ne pourrait plus
être invalidée par un juge nombreux sont
ceux qui critiquent le Premier ministre
israélien d'être personnellement motivé
dans ces changements puisqu'il est
inculpé dans plusieurs affaires de
corruption et les changements lui
permettraient de faire annuler les
accusations qui pèsent contre lui ce
gouvernement malheureusement est biaisé
par des
par des situations personnelles les gens
ne s'attendaient pas qui va y avoir des
manifestations
d'une ampleur aussi grande
le mouvement populaire qui a commencé au
début de l'année avec le dépôt de la
réforme et même appuyé par le président
israélien Isaac
herzoga l'ensemble de la législation
actuellement discutée au sein de la
Commission doit être retirée de la table
a-t-il déclaré jeudi ça peut dégringoler
à quelque chose qui va être malsain et
mauvais pour l'État d'Israël
le projet de réforme doit être discuté
d'ici mercredi au parlement israélien la
knees 7 les manifestants eux sont prêts
à revenir dans la rue s'il le faut ici
Carla Oliveira Radio-Canada Montréal